when you have to do something really
important right now
unlocking your phone opening an app and
navigating to the right place is a lot
of work on API 24 and higher devices
though there's an alternative a quick
settings tile now your app can provide
its own tiles for quick access to
critical functionality once users have
manually added your tile they'll be able
to view your tile by swiping down the
notification tray either as just an icon
if you're in the first few spots or with
up to two lines of text and the icon in
the full Quick Settings panel even
better the full Quick Settings panel is
available even if the device is locked
users can then tap on your quick setting
style to trigger a callback where you
can kick off some background work show a
dialog or start an activity now that's
pretty useful for those really frequent
or urgent tasks and that's really what
Quick Settings tiles are all about
they're not just for launching your app
you have a home screen icon for that so
think about the critical operations that
can be very easily understood with a
simple icon and a quick tap or through a
simple dialog to provide a bit more
context now your Quick Settings tile is
going to be controlled and managed
through a tile service note that your
app name will be displayed right next to
the name of the quick settings tile so
give a descriptive name and icon that
hints at what it actually does space is
pretty limited here so keep it under 18
characters for the label the icon here
should be solid white on a transparent
background think of it as just the Alpha
Channel remember you can use a vector
drawable as your only be enabled on API
24 in higher devices the lifecycle of a
quick setting style is a bit different
from many services though it has three
main parts first when your tile is added
to the quick settings panel the system
will bind to your service and call on
tile added after that each
I'm your tile is visible the system will
yet again bind to your tile service and
call on start listening this is the
point where you're expected to keep the
tile up-to-date all the way until you
receive a call back to on stop listening
which is when the tile is no longer
visible these make a natural pairing if
you need to set up any listeners for
changes finally when I mean if the user
were to ever remove your tile you'd
again of the system bind to your service
and call on tile removed keep in mind
that the life cycle is controlled by the
system here so don't assume that your
service will persist between these
states there's another mode called
active mode read the blog post LinkedIn
that is a description for how that
differs from the passive mode described
here okay let's say we've received a
call back to on start listening and we
want to update our tile you'll called
get qsr tile to get the tile instance
associated with the tile service this is
what allows you to update the icon label
and content description also allows you
to set the state of the tile there are
three states for a tile active
corresponds the on or enabled state
inactive is off or disabled state and
the system automatically tints your icon
to indicate the inactive state really
useful if you have a tile that naturally
fits with an on/off toggle model and
finally the unavailable state this would
be appropriate if your tile needs
internet access and you're offline for
instance users can't click on your tile
when it's unavailable unlike the other
two states just remember once you've
updated everything you need you need to
call update tile this is what actually
triggers the system to update your tile
it's one other pretty core part to a
quick sighting style though handling
clicks you'll get a call back to your
tile services on click method whenever
the user taps your tile
from here you have a few options most
common cases you want to do some
background work toggling some internal
state in your app and updating your tile
with the new state you can also display
a dialog using this show dialog method
this is useful if the tile switches
between more than two states or you feel
the user needs some additional context
such as what remote device is being
changed or that you need to download or
upload some information there's also a
start activity and collapse method for
starting an activity directly from the
tile service don't forget though users
will be able to access your tile even if
the device is securely locked if you
have something sensitive consider
checking is secure and modifying your
behavior to only show non sensitive
information if the quick settings panel
is above the lock screen is locked low
return true in this state you won't be
able to use show dialog and you'll have
to make sure any activity you start uses
flag show when locked to show above the
lock screen there is a convenience
method unlock and run that will prompt
the user to unlock their device if your
click handling requires an unlocked
device so quick setting styles are a
great way to give quick access to
critical functionality in your app make
sure they're intuitive and save these
our time throughout the entire lifetime
of the app you'll find them a great way
to build better apps